It's a promise problem. And like the Bernstein-Vazirani problem, the promise involves some string s that we can view as being a hidden string,
and also like the
Bernstein-Vazirani problem, the goal is to output
this hidden string s.
The promise is more
complicated this time though, so let's take it apart and
understand what it's saying.
To begin, let's just read it. It says that there exists a string s having length equal to n
such that a particular "if"
and "only if" condition is true for all choices of n bits strings x and y.
Specifically, it must
be the case that f of x is equal to f of y if and only if one of
two possibilities holds.
The first possibility is that x equals y, and the second possibility is that by taking the
bitwise eXclusive OR of x
in the hidden string s, we get Y.
This turns out to be a
pretty strict promise in the sense that most
functions won't satisfy it.
Only very special functions
satisfy this condition.
Now, to get a better grasp on this promise and therefore on the problem itself, we'll consider two main cases.
The first case is that s
is the all-zero string.
In this case, we can simplify the "if"
and "only if" statement in the promise because the bitwise
eXclusive OR of any string x
with the all-zero string
is simply the string x.
So the condition simplifies
to f of x is equal to f of y if and only if x equals y.
And that's just another way of saying that f is a one to one function.
In other words, the string f of x must be unique
for each possible string x.
So if f is a one to one function, then the promise is indeed satisfied, specifically for s being
the all-zero string,
and in this case, that's
the correct output.
The second case is that s
is not the all-zero string, and what this implies is that the function f must be two to one.
So for every input string x, there's exactly one other string that f maps to the same
string that x maps to,
and moreover, the other string
must be the string we get by taking the bitwise
eXclusive OR of x with s.
Another way of saying this
is that every n bit string x has a partner, and that partner is the string that we get
by taking the bitwise eXclusive OR with s.
Any two partners must give
us the same output string if we plug them into f, and no other strings are allowed to give us
that same output string.
So these are necessarily distinct strings that partners produce.
Here's an example of a function like this described by its table of values.
So this is a function
from 3 bits to 5 bits.
If we stare at this table
of values for a while, we find that the promise is
satisfied for the string 011.
000 and 011 are partners. XORing either one of them
by s gives us the other,
and they take the same output value, which is 10011 in this particular case, and no other strings produce
that same output string.
001 and 010 are partners because XORing either
one by s gives the other, and they produce the same output value,
which again, isn't produced
by any other string.
And the situation is
similar for 100 and 111 as well as 101 and 110.
So if the input to the
problem is this function, the correct answer is the string 011.
Like I said before, most functions don't satisfy this promise, it's a very specific condition.
It should also be noted that
if the promise is satisfied, it can only be satisfied for one string s.
So there's always only one
correct answer to this problem.
So that is Simon's problem. Like I said, it's hard to imagine a practical situation in which you'd wanna solve this problem,
but that isn't the point. The point is to try to figure out what quantum computers are good at, and it turns out that they're far superior
to classical algorithms for
solving this particular problem.
Now let's take a look
at Simon's algorithm, which solves Simon's problem.
The algorithm consists of
running the quantum circuit that you see here several times, followed by a classical
post-processing step,
and we'll be more specific about what several
times means a bit later.
The circuit looks very similar
to the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, this time because the function
f maps n bits to m bits,
the query gate is different. Rather than just a single
qubit on the bottom, we now have m qubits on the bottom
and n on the top like before.
A key difference is that we're
not setting up a minus state or multiple minus states on the bottom.
These bottom qubits are all
initialized to the 0 state, and those states go straight
into the query gate.